So now, a key thing here is
that we have to also make sure
of another important property.
And I don't recall you saying exactly
that the contents of the output has
to be the same as
the contents of the input.
So, if we had input which was three,
two, one, and
we had output which was four,
five, six, that is in order, okay?
And it is integers.
But I don't think it's what we would
mean by saying that the output
was a sorted version of input.
>> Okay.
>> So you want to try again here?
>> Yeah, let me make sure I have what
you just said, correct in my head.
So, given a input vector of three,
two, one.
>> Right.
>> We're going to map that to four,
five, six.
>> So,
is that a legitimate output of the sort,
what we're trying to do
in the sort routine?
>> No, it's not.
So we need to say something along
the lines of that for every
element in the output vector y, that
element exists in the input vector x.
>> So it better be the case.
We're not allowed to
have that 456 there.
So once again if we started with three,
two,
one, how about an output that is one,
one, one, two, three?
Okay, so we have three two one, and
that's going to map to one one,
did you say two three?
Something like that.
>> Yeah sure.
>> Okay.
All right so, we also need to say
something then about, I guess,
the cardinality, or the, how many
times the elements appear in the input
vector x, they need to appear that same
number of times in the output vector y.
>> Okay, so for
everything in the input it's got to, for
every individual item in the input,
it has to show up as a separate
individual item than in the output.
Well how about if we then take three,
two,
one, and map it to one,
two, three, four?
So it satisfies your specification.
>> Right, so
we can't have any new elements appear
either in the output vector y.
It sounds like we're getting
a little verbose with our
original definition here.
>> So you're not comfortable that we've
captured what seems to be a simple
concept of sorting, okay,
in a similarly simple expression
of what the specification is.
Okay, and If you think about it for
a minute, sorting is pretty simple.
If you imagine trying to
specify the software on
the International Space Station or
something you'd better get right or
if doesn't work there are safety issues,
it
makes sense to spend some time in trying
to state precisely what's going on here.